[Applause]
fans of Prince Harry and Megan Markel
went crazy on April 2nd when the royal
couple launched their very own Instagram
accounts Sussex royal but after less
than a month of sweet posts royal
watchers noticed a few clues that have
us wondering is Megan personally running
the account there was so much more that
I wanted to share ET is breaking
everything down what did you figure out
the most obvious reason we think it
could be mm behind the screen is the
spelling in the captions Megan is
American and we've seen several
american-style spellings instead of
British ones
check out the word organization here
it's spelled with a Z not an S same
thing again with the word re-energised
your platform is social media so it
allows you to have a big voice and reach
lots of people who knew next up diapers
a word used by Americans when Brits
usually say nappies I wasn't persuade as
you are in Memphis my name is Ruth Laird
and check this out they even mentioned
currency in both forms dollars and
pounds one last suspicion emojis which
we rarely see on other royal accounts
[Applause]
it's not the first time Harry and
Megan's page has stirred up excitement
the account actually broke a world
record for reaching a million followers
less than six hours after it debuted we
also generally couldn't think of a
better place to announce the upcoming
baby up next for the couple they're
becoming parents a source recently told
ET quote Harry's attention is completely
absorbed with the birth of his first
child he can't wait to become a father
he's been doing everything he can to put
Megan at ease I never thought my life
would be that awesome as for Megan our
source says she'll be a fantastic mother
adding quote she is so wonderful with
children and they are both so excited
you